We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. In the US, they're called lines in Canada. They're called lineups sometimes. And I was once interviewed live on Canadian National Radio,
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加州及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量的使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentry.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是 99% Invisible。我是罗曼·马尔斯。在美国，人们管这叫 lines，在加拿大。有时他们管这叫 lineups。我曾有一次在加拿大国家广播电台接受现场采访，
and they started talking about lineups, and we had a conversation about police for five minutes until I realized what they started talking about lineups and we had a conversation about police for five minutes until I realized what they were talking about. But pretty much everywhere else, it's known as a cue. I like cue the best. Yeah, me too. That's Benjamin Walker. He's obsessed with cues.
他们开始谈论 lineups，我们谈论了五分钟的警察，直到我意识到他们开始谈论 lineups，我们谈论了五分钟的警察，直到我意识到他们在谈论什么。但几乎在其他所有地方，它都被称为 cue。我最喜欢 cue。是的，我也是。那是本杰明·沃克。他痴迷于排队。
He keeps sending me emails with links to YouTube videos of cues you have. Psychology students filming their surreptitious cue experiments. You have Asian road rage videos. You've got people filming fights that break out in Q's. Unless you're gonna physically move me, nothing's gonna happen. So understand that I'm not getting out of this. Understand. Then none of them are gonna stop this. And you can understand. Then I'm gonna stop being in the house. I like to call YouTube the Q-hole. And when I found this lecture by Dr. Q, I immediately made an appointment to go and see him.
他不断给我发电子邮件，里面附有你所经历的排队情况的 YouTube 视频链接。心理学学生拍摄他们秘密排队的实验。有亚洲路怒视频。你还会看到人们拍摄在队列中爆发的冲突的视频。除非你打算把我物理移开，否则什么都不会发生。所以请明白我不会离开这个地方。明白。然后他们谁也无法阻止这一切。你也可以明白。然后我就不会离开屋子了。我喜欢把 YouTube 称为 Q-hole（排队黑洞）。当我发现 Q 博士的这个讲座时，我立即预约去见他。
I'm Dick Larson. I'm a professor at MIT. And I guess my nickname is Dr. Q. Dick Larson is a Q theorist. Just about every day we experience Q-ing in some aspect of our lives. Dick Larson studies the mathematical and psychological models of Q-ing systems. Unfortunately, oftentimes too many Q's on a day-to-day basis. Dr. Q's able to put his professional knowledge to work everywhere he goes.
我是迪克·拉尔森。我是麻省理工学院的一名教授。我想我的绰号是 Q 博士。迪克·拉尔森是一位排队论专家。几乎每天，我们生活中的某些方面都会经历排队。迪克·拉尔森研究排队系统的数学和心理学模型。不幸的是，在日常生活中往往有太多的队伍。Q 博士能够将他的专业知识运用到他去的任何地方。
I have my own ways through supermarkets, particularly if you have to go to the Delay counter and get a number, you run to the Delay counter as soon as you go into the supermarket, get your number, and then you start walking around and doing the regular shopping and you watch how the numbers go drop down. And then as soon as it gets close to yours, then you go back. So that's a cue that's been avoided because it's a cue within a cue. So I have little little ideas like this. Dr. Cue hates waiting in line as much as you and I do,
我有自己逛超市的方式，特别是如果你必须去熟食柜台拿个号，你一进超市就得跑到熟食柜台，拿了号，然后你就可以开始四处走动进行常规购物，并看着号码是怎么往下掉的。一旦数字接近你的号码，你就回去。所以这是一个被避免的排队，因为它是排队中的排队。所以我有一些这样的小想法。Q 博士和你我一样讨厌排队等待，
but he does respect the well-designed queue. The Maccabellan experts of Cue design are people in the Disney world and the Disney properties. They have mastered the idea that people can be happy waiting 40 minutes in line for a four-minute ride. I think it's fantastic. Disney is very serious about QDesign. They employ about 18 or so operations researchers. They call them Imagineers. These Imagineers have mastered the golden rules of QDes design. The first is to keep your customers entertained while they wait in line.
但他确实尊重设计良好的队伍。排队设计领域的马基雅维利式专家是迪士尼世界和迪士尼乐园的人。他们掌握了这样一个理念：人们可以开心地排队 40 分钟去玩一个四分钟的游乐项目。我认为这太棒了。迪士尼非常重视排队设计。他们雇用了大约 18 名运筹学研究人员。他们称他们为幻想工程师。这些幻想工程师掌握了排队设计的黄金法则。第一条是让顾客在排队时保持娱乐。
They're guests. Think that the amusement has started before they actually sit on the ride. They'll have video screens along the Q route with games, and if the lines are getting really ugly, a park manager will send in a sweaty man and a full-body costume. And so they're entertained and they're amused while they're waiting in line. The second rule, manage expectations. Always manage your expectations such that you'll deliver above the performance you say.
他们是客人。他们认为在真正坐上游乐设施之前，娱乐就已经开始了。他们会在排队路线沿途设置带有游戏的视频屏幕，如果队伍变得真的很糟糕，公园经理会派出一个穿着全身服装、汗流浃背的人。因此他们在排队时得到了娱乐和消遣。第二条规则，管理期望。始终管理好你的期望，让你的交付成果超出你的预期。
So for instance, if the line says you can anticipate 45 minute wait if the line is out to this point, but really it might be only 35 minutes. So therefore, if you look at your watch in 35 minutes, you're getting on the line and the dad, you're in the mom and the two kids say, hey, we're 10 minutes ahead of schedule. So that's great.
例如，如果队伍显示如果排到这个地方，你可以预计等待 45 分钟，但实际上可能只需要 35 分钟。因此，如果在 35 分钟时你看了看手表，你排上了队，爸爸、妈妈和两个孩子就会说，嘿，我们比预定时间提前了 10 分钟。所以这太棒了。
You waited 35 minutes and you say, we just saved 10 minutes because we thought we're gonna have to wait for 45 minutes. Q-theories about a hundred years old now, but it wasn't until the 1950s that the profession really came into its own. After World War II, there was a burst of economic activity, a lot more high-rise buildings, high-rise hotels, and offices, and all of a sudden, owners of these buildings are getting complaints
你等了 35 分钟，然后你说，我们刚刚节省了 10 分钟，因为我们以为必须等待 45 分钟。排队论大约有一百年的历史了，但直到 20 世纪 50 年代，这个行业才真正迎来了它的全盛时期。二战后，经济活动爆发，出现了更多的高层建筑、高层酒店和办公室，突然之间，这些建筑的业主开始接到投诉
about rush hour delays for elevators. In those days, of course, they didn't have microprocessors to optimize the movement of the elevators. Many of the elevators actually had humans as operators, as pilots, so to speak. So Russ A. Kauf, who was a professor at University of Pennsylvania, sent one of his research aids to New York City to check out these complaints about elevator delays. And indeed, he found out that there were rush hours for elevators, like eight to nine in the morning or five to six at night,
关于上下班高峰期电梯延误的投诉。当然，在那个年代，他们还没有微处理器来优化电梯的运行。许多电梯实际上是由人类作为操作员，也就是所谓的驾驶员来控制的。因此，宾夕法尼亚大学教授鲁斯·A·考夫派遣他的一名研究助理前往纽约市去调查这些关于电梯延误的投诉。果然，他发现电梯也有高峰期，比如早上八点到九点，或者晚上五点到六点，
just like rush hour for cars. So he said, hmm, the traditional engineering approach. Dynamite this building, it start over again with twice as many elevator shafts, because you've got more demand than you have capacity in these rush hours. In my experience, engineers are a lot more crafty than that, but let's just go with it. But then in a stroke of genius, he said, well, maybe the problem is framed the wrong way. Maybe the problem isn't the 90 seconds of weight for the elevators.
就像汽车的高峰期一样。所以他说，嗯，传统的工程方法。炸毁这座建筑，重新开始，电梯井数量加倍，因为在这些高峰期，需求大于容量。以我的经验，工程师要狡猾得多，但我们就按这个来吧。但接着，在神来之笔的一刻，他说，嗯，也许问题被错误地框定了。也许问题不是等电梯的 90 秒。
Maybe the problem is the complaints about the 90 second weights for the elevators. And if we could reduce the complaints substantially, maybe we'll solve the problem. And then another stroke of genius, he said, well, what if you give somebody a distraction, a diversion? Let's try Florida ceiling mirrors next to all the elevators in an experimental building.
也许问题是对等电梯 90 秒的投诉。如果我们能大幅减少投诉，也许我们就能解决问题。接着又是一个神来之笔，他说，嗯，如果你给某人一些分散注意力、转移视线的东西会怎么样？让我们在一栋实验大楼的所有电梯旁尝试从地板到天花板的镜子。
So you got the money, put the mirrors in, watched for a month, and guess what? The complaints dropped to near zero. A man who were wearing ties could adjust their ties, a woman could make sure their hair was organized okay. Or vice versa. Sometimes men and women were even seen to flirt occasionally through the reflection, I guess it's less provocative than night eye contact. The complaints dropped in their zero problem solve, the statistics of the delay unchanged. Ingenious. Mirrors won't work if McDonald's are whole foods, though.
于是你拿到了资金，装上了镜子，观察了一个月，你猜怎么着？投诉量骤降至接近零。戴领带的男士可以整理领带，女士可以确保发型整理妥当。或者反过来。有时甚至偶尔会看到男女通过反射调情，我想这比直接的眼神接触不那么挑衅。投诉量骤降至接近零，问题得到解决，延误的统计数据保持不变。绝妙。不过，如果是在麦当劳或全食超市，镜子就行不通了。
Many fast food restaurants and most grocery stores use parallel cues, where there's a bunch of open lanes and you're forced to pick one and stick with it. The one next to you could be going faster for any number of reasons and it's totally frustrating, but you stay in your line and you play the hand you're dealt. But there's another way to do it. A single serpentine line that feeds all of the open registers.
许多快餐店和大多数杂货店都使用平行队列，即有一堆开放的通道，你被迫选择一个并坚持下去。由于各种原因，你旁边的那个队列可能移动得更快，这让人完全沮丧，但你留在你的队列里，接受你得到的牌。但还有另一种方法。一条单一的蛇形队伍，为所有开放的收银台提供服务。
It's first come, first served. It's a queue designed for equality and fairness. And when there's one line, both blatant and inadvertent queue jumping is minimized. We call them slips and skips. In American companies, they used to pride themselves on designing these more egalitarian queues. Wendy's is very proud that they're the first ones
这是先到先服务。这是一个为平等和公平而设计的队列。当只有一条队伍时，公然和无意的插队行为被降到最低。我们称之为 slips（溜缝）和 skips（跳排）。在美国公司，他们过去以设计这些更具 egalitarian（平等主义）的队列而自豪。Wendy's（温迪汉堡）非常自豪他们是第一家
in fast food that had the single-surpentine line. American Airlines is very proud. They claimed that they're the first ones that have single serpentine line in airports, although British air argues with them. They say, well, they got at the same time. They used to be a bank in New York called Chemical Bank, and they used to claim that they were the first ones to have that in their bank lobbies. And so there's a certain pride to getting rid of, in a written line jumping by slips and
在快餐领域采用单一蛇形队伍的餐厅。美国航空公司非常自豪。他们声称自己是机场中第一个采用单一蛇形队伍的公司，尽管英国航空公司对此提出了异议。他们说，嗯，他们是同时采用的。纽约过去有一家名为化学银行的银行，他们曾声称自己是第一家在银行大厅里采用这种方式的银行。因此，通过采用单一蛇形队伍，消除明里暗里的插队现象，
skips by having the single serpentine line. But today, cue design is changing. More and more, we're encountering cues that are designed so that different levels of service can be provided to different groups of people. Priority cues and given certain people, priorities over others, you can see it in amusements like Disney, but more seriously, it occurs in some life and death situations like queuing for organ donation transplants. My hypothesis is that this design change is connected to the Q-rage that's becoming more and more commonplace
这带有一种自豪感。但今天，排队设计正在改变。我们越来越多地遇到这样设计的队列：可以为不同的人群提供不同级别的服务。优先队列赋予某些人优先于其他人的权力，你可以在迪士尼等游乐场所看到这一点，但更严重的是，它发生在一些生死攸关的情况下，比如器官捐赠移植排队。我的假设是，这种设计变化与越来越普遍的排队狂怒有关
and available to watch for free on YouTube. And I also believe that understanding this new Q-theory will better help us understand the inequality and disparity that's on the rise in this country. Yeah, you might say, well, why should somebody with a lot of frequent firemiles get automatically bumped up to first class? As I found out, I recently was on some flights and therefore have to then escape the TSA queue for in airports. And I feel a little bit guilty about that. And just yesterday I did this twice.
并且可以在 YouTube 上免费观看。我也相信，理解这种新的排队论将更好地帮助我们理解这个日益加剧的不平等和差距。是的，你可能会说，为什么拥有大量常旅客里程的人应该自动升入头等舱？正如我所发现的，我最近坐过几次飞机，因此不得不避开机场的 TSA 队列。我为此感到有点内疚。就在昨天我还这样做了两次。
And I felt a little bit guilty because there were like 30 people in line and I went right to the front of it. And I thought, hmm, why is this fair? Just because I fly a little bit more than the others do. And so I think your question is a deep one and requires some more thought and discussion. 99% Invisible was produced this week by Benjamin Walker and me Roman Mars. Do I have to tell you about Benjamin Walker again? Too much information from WFMU? Understand it will make your life better. This is a project of KALW91.7 local public radio in San Francisco and the American Institute
我感到有点内疚，因为队伍里大约有 30 个人，而我直接走到了最前面。我想，嗯，这怎么公平？仅仅因为我比其他人飞得稍微多一点。所以我认为你的问题很深刻，需要更多的思考和讨论。本杰明·沃克和我罗曼·马尔斯制作了本周的 99% Invisible。我还要向你介绍本杰明·沃克吗？来自 WFMU 的信息太多了？请理解它会让你的生活变得更好。这是旧金山本地公共广播电台 KALW 91.7 的一个项目，也是美国建筑师学会
of Architects in San Francisco. This program is distributed by PRX, the public radio exchange making public radio more public find out more at PRX.org. This week and every week I am aided and abetted by Sam Greenspan working all the way over in Baltimore, Maryland, home of the third best city flag in the country. Fuck it up. It's a good one. You can find the show and like the show on Facebook. I tweet at Roman Mars.
在旧金山的合作项目。该节目由 PRX 发行，这是一个让公共广播更加公开的公共广播交易所，了解更多信息请访问 PRX.org。本周以及每周，都有山姆·格林斯潘协助我，他在马里兰州巴尔的摩工作，那里拥有全美第三好的城市旗帜。去他的。这是一面很好的旗帜。你可以在 Facebook 上找到并点赞该节目。我在推特上的账号是 Roman Mars。
Get you know, it's just catch up with us. And tell us your Q stories at 99%invisible.org.大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい大きい待ってみます待ってる 私たち待ってみます 待ってる 私たち待ってみます you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
了解一下，和我们叙叙旧。并在 99%invisible.org 上告诉我们你的排队故事。